COUPLE OF GAMES AND THEY GOT THE
WITH
NICK LEDDY MOVES IT AROUND FOR
COUPLE OF GAMES AND WITH A BETT
OPPORTUNITY.
THE WORST WAY.
LOVED ON THE FACE-OFF.
DINEEN BEHIND COULDN'T HANDLEYZ
MAKING PROGRESS THE LAST IT OUT-
>> THERE GOES LARKIN,AY.
>> AND ANOTHER BREAKDOWN BY THE
COYOTES, DEFENSE WAS CAUGHT UP
BOARDS.  ]
ARE OUT THERE FOR DETROIT.
AND RAYMOND.
DROP AND A SHOT RIPPED WIDE BY
LINDSTROM.   ICING CALL.
>> NAMESTNIKOV IS SURE GOING TO
WANT THIS
WITHOUT A DEKEYSER OFF THE FACE
THEY'RE TAKING SOME CHANCES
HERE.
>> ONLY A COUPLE OFHEY GET A
WHISTLE OFF SIDE AGAINST THE
COYOTES SO THEEN ALONG WITH JAK
BUT AGAIN, BARRETT HAYTON
ELEVATING AS WELL.
AND RIGHT BACK IN GOES CHYCHRUN
AND NOW KELLER.  TYSON.
>> FABBRI'S SHOT, GOES LYUBUSHKN
COULDN'T KEEP AND 7:40 IT AS WE
THEY CAN SMELL IT.
>> SO HERE IS THEDZINGEL HERE O
COYOTES WIN PUMPED UP HERE.
HERE IS THE SHOT BY DINEEN, AND
THERE'S THE OFF.
ROUSSEL.
BEHIND THE NET.   COME RIGHT BAT
YOU.
THEIR TRANSITION GAME IS
AND DETROIT BRINGS
MICHIGAN AND OHIO STATE ON
KESSEL HAS GOT IT.
DROPS IT, KELLER TO THE NET.